this morning we're tackling a subject
that affects most american women and
rarely gets discussed openly it's period
pain cramps and everything else that
comes with it according to one study
about 80 percent of women report being
less productive at work or school while
on their periods we met one ceo trying
to change the narrative around period
pain by giving men the opportunity to
know how it feels
tick-tock videos have gotten tens of
millions of views showing men trying a
period pain simulator but for this
entrepreneur it's for more than just the
laughs it raises awareness and also
highlights a condition many women have
been battling their whole life the
painful uterine tissue disorder
endometriosis
the pain can be debilitating
and overwhelming
but typically period cramps go unnoticed
by men
how can we function like this you can't
until now
we put them where you would have ovaries
if men had them lux perry is ceo and
co-founder of some days a canadian
period pain relief company their team
brought their electric period pain
simulator to this year's calgary
stampede where they managed to bring the
toughest of cowboys to their knees
what's the most surprising reaction
you've seen i'm actually genuinely
surprised over and over again by the
compassion and the empathy that
men display in these moments cram cream
always helps me when i'm on my view
they're trying to use the simulator to
take the stigma out of talking about
period pains
the simulator and what some days is
really trying to do
is open up that conversation in a way
that's not awkward it's funny it's
lighthearted
[Applause]
but it hasn't always been a laughing
matter for perry who suffers from
endometriosis it impacted my ability to
attend school my ability to attend jobs
hold a job endometriosis is regularly
mistaken for period pain which is just
so absolutely absurd endometriosis often
causes more extreme pain during
menstrual periods when you do the
simulator what pain level are you
usually at so i usually tell people that
i'm a 10.
don't look so scared are you kidding me
so i decided to test my pain level and
corralled my producer to join me i'll
never be ready for the simulator
i'm ready
i went first as the baseline tester do
you want to call this your your baseline
this would be my baseline yeah okay yeah
then producer ewing was hooked up and
while i didn't flinch ewan had a tougher
time with the cramping
whoa
are you serious this is jamie's baseline
this is your baseline
yeah do you want to try standing up
sure
do i have to
and he's still at an eight yeah oh
okay
all right so it's at the the wave where
it's come off now yeah now it's coming
back
this is usually where i go get oh my god
my whole legs are like cramping up i can
hardly move my legs
i reminded him the machine doesn't
include the headaches bloating and
bleeding well yeah i'm very sorry that
you have to go through this
thank you that's why i'm here that's the
validation yeah
and that's really what it's about for
the company is having that empathy